did you detect anything from afar that
tom brady was behaving like a guy who
knew he was in his final year with the
patriots
well i i had heard rumors i had and i
you know again i'll say this one big
sign to me was i believe the end of
october when adam schefter went on espn
and gave a big long report how he didn't
think tom brady would be back
with the new england patriots in the
next year and that was the first thing i
remember hearing going wow schefter
wouldn't come on tv and say that unless
he's hearing that from somebody very
very reliable now
added to that mike i mean with the ota
conversation and brady not attending
otas what was it the last two seasons
you know
mike what what did anybody expect to
happen there did they really think like
bill belichick was gonna be like oh okay
starting quarterback no problem don't
come to otas anymore everything's good
so to me that was the most interesting
part of the whole interview that told me
right there that was the start of the
end because as you know and as you can
imagine
in belichick new england they want
everybody there
working being detailed doing the new
england way and brady wasn't there and i
got to imagine that was kind of the
start of the end right there
al michaels was on lunch talk live with
mike tarico yesterday and he repeated a
comment from tom brady as the patriots
were preparing to play the ravens last
season at a time when the patriots were
8 and 0. tom brady in the production
meeting told al michaels and chris
collinsworth i'm the most miserable
eight no quarterback in the nfl and al
joked yesterday that he still thought
the odds for brady leaving were 43 000
to 1 and ultimately we know what
happened brady left let's hear a little
bit more from tom brady yesterday with
howard stern brady regarding who gets
the credit for what has happened in new
england over the last 20 years him or
bill belichick
it's got to be somewhat annoying
when there's always this question tom
brady greatest of all time but if he
didn't have belichick it wouldn't have
achieved because belichick is the brains
there i don't think i think it's a
pretty straight argument actually that
people would say that because again i
can't do his job and he can't do mine so
the fact that you could say would i be
successful without him the same level of
success i don't believe i would have
been but i feel the same
and
vice versa as well to have him
allowed me to be the best i could be so
i'm grateful for that and i very much
believe that he feels the same without
me because we've expressed that to each
other
you know i'm always probing for bs when
people are giving these kinds of answers
but i actually believe this and i buy
this i get it the way bill belichick was
the way that he is gets the most out of
his players the players who submit to
the patriot way if you're not going to
submit to the patriot way bill
belichick's method for pressing buttons
won't work but if you are all in with
the way they do things belichick knows
how to get the most out of you and he
doesn't get it out of you by praising
you he gets it out of you by being
demanding by having a high bar and by
constantly needling you the way bill
parcells handled your dad back in the
day
no doubt i mean again you know he's he's
the general uh you know the general the
battleship he wants to make sure
everybody's on their p's and q's
nobody's nobody's getting a free pass or
a pat on the back at times hey good job
you're doing wonderful here no he's
going to keep you on your toes he wants
to keep your competitive juices flowing
yes he played games like that i don't
want to say games like that it's just he
knows what it takes to make players
compete and play at their highest level
and i think that's the big thing and i
agree with brady in a lot of ways i mean
listen do i think tom brady um you know
i'm going gonna give bill belichick more
of the credit you know that
but do i think if tom brady would have
won super bowls somewhere else with
another team that at least had somewhat
of a supporting cast and a good coach
yes absolutely you know but do i think
bill belichick is of course the
mastermind behind the you know architect
of the the new england patriots of what
they are yes i mean you talk to chris
collinsworth or al michaels or phil sims
or troy aikman or tony romo anybody
that's been following the nfl uh as far
as like broadcasting games they would
tell you when you walk into new england
things are done a different way it's a
different feel it's a different vibe and
that was set forth by bill belichick
brady was the perfect
perfect you know what do i want to say
uh sergeant sergeant general to be on
the field with the troops daily carrying
the message from the coach into the
locker room with the players and that's
why it works so well
it's kind of like the old school
parenting approach the withholding of
emotion by the dad right the withholding
of praise by the dad the constant
expectation to do better be better live
up to a higher standard and the fear
that if you ever say
good job son
sun's going to get soft right
yes i mean that's what it is you're
you're exactly right i mean how many
times you know i know i've said this to
you before but
you know i know the one thing i learned
when i was working there in new england
is the patriots coaches felt like wes
welker played better when he was pissed
off so they made sure they found a way
to piss them off on a weekly basis i
mean that's what they did because they
knew they were going to get the best wes
welker come sunday and yes that's you
know that's the job of a great head
coach it's not to sit there and be your
best friend all the time it's to get the
most out of you and i think brady will
appreciate it more and belichick will
appreciate brady moore when this is all
said and done you know but i think you
know the other thing when we go back
into like you know the when it was at
the end right and i talked about the
otas earlier you know that i would think
before the year there was some talks
about con you know contract i'm sure
brady got a feel for what new england
was willing to give him as far as
money-wise he probably was like whoa i
don't like that and then he's also going
man this has been a 20-year grind with
the biggest curmudgeon in the history of
the nfl and i think all those things led
to him knowing there was a good chance
he was going to leave after the 2019
season
and one other point too and not to
psycho analyze tom brady here but you
and i have had the conversation in the
past that his reputation for always
taking less money than he could have
gotten didn't necessarily have its roots
in a desire to be a team player that was
going to be surrounded by a bunch of
great teammates it was constant fear
that someday bill belichick was going to
wake up
look at the balance sheet look at how
much money is devoted to the quarterback
look at where the quarterback currently
is and make the very dispassionate cold
decision sorry we can't have this guy
anymore we're going to go with his
backup we're going to find someone else
and i think after 20 years of that fear
he may have gotten to a point where he
decided i'm going to jump before i get
pushed because at some point over the
next few years father time is going to
diminish my game to the point where i am
going to get pushed
i i think so mike i think there is
something to that yes i was always led
to believe that it wasn't tom brady
volunteering for oh i'll take less for
everybody else that it was an ultimatum
more or less in a lot of ways by new
england like no this is what it is you
could take it we're going to build a
good team or we'll move on and you know
whether they would have done that or not
i don't know but yes you were right that
would lead to the detention the
exhaustion of a player constantly having
to prove himself on a daily basis and
probably did want a little bit of a pat
on the back or a pat on the butt to just
go hey man tom you're doing a great job
but that's just not bill's way and now
you know tom who's a great competitor he
gets re-energized and gets to go to the
tampa bay buccaneers and prove to people
that hey i could do this without bill
belichick and he's certainly going to be
the biggest show in town and in the nfl
anytime tampa's on tv it's going to be a
huge deal and you know and belichick i
don't think is going to take it personal
mike i you know belichick is too much of
a curmudgeon it's i don't think
belichick's gonna get on the bus after a
game and go let me see what tom brady in
tampa did where
i can maybe see it being more the other
way around with brady paying attention
to england uh you know just because
belichick is so driven and always on to
the next task
i
was sufficiently impressed by tom
brady's explanation of what he could
have done without bill what bill could
have done without him what they managed
to do together it passed the bs meter
test for me the next topic we're going
to share with you though
the bs meter is pinging a little bit on
this one let's hear some more from tom
brady with howard stern on wednesday
i never cared about legacy i mean i
could give a kid about that's never i
never once when i was in high school
said man i can't wait for my what my
football legacy looks like
it's just not me that's not my
personality so
why would i
choose a different place
it's because it was just time i don't
know what to say other than that like i
had done everything i accomplished
everything i could in two decades
with an incredible organization
incredible group of people and that will
never change and no one can ever take
that away from me no one can ever take
those experience or super bowl
championships away from us
i don't buy for a second that tom brady
doesn't care about legacy we all care
about legacy legacy motivates us in many
different ways you don't win six super
bowls if you don't give a bleep about
legacy chris
well yeah i i think so and you know i
believe him in the fact that i don't
think he was worried about legacy in
high school or college
or probably even the early days of his
nfl career but once you win three super
bowls and then people start to talk
about oh if you win more one more you're
with joe montana and terry bradshaw and
then he lost two super bowls in a row
and it looked like oh my gosh seattle's
on the two-yard line and they're gonna
lose the third super bowl in a row how
could this be
yes i think he became legacy aware
towards the end of his career and that's
not a bad thing you're right mike i mean
of course you should be you know it's
part of the competitive nature of any
great athlete uh but i think the thing
that i love about tom brady is
yes legacy surely important to him and
we know that i mean he wouldn't have
been taking pictures of you know six
rings on twitter last year with julian
edelman but at the same time he's like
the most selfl selfless
quarterback of a star team as we've ever
seen and that's where i really do
respect him i mean yeah he was willing
to not you know kick and scream for
taking less and he did all the things
that belichick wanted to do on a daily
and weekly and yearly basis and that's
where tom brady is really really special
let alone you know his toughness and his
great right arm and his ability to to
deliver in the clutch he's you know
arguably the clutches quarterback in the
history of the sport i don't think
there's any denying that
i just don't believe that in that stew
of motivation that prompted him to go
from being
a sixth-round pick 199th overall if you
haven't heard well to being the greatest
quarterback of all time that
consideration of legacy wasn't there
every step of the way joe montana was
his hero growing up he wanted to be joe
montana and i know he said yesterday he
won't say whether or not he was better
than joe montana he's better than joe
montana he he one-upped or two-upped as
the case may be his his idol and that
surely was part of what drove him every
step of the way the scott pioli story
about seeing him in the practice bubble
on a friday night when no one else is
around that's just not proving people
wrong for failing to draft him that is
establishing a legacy better than the
guy you grew up idolizing no i mean no
doubt about it but you know it also like
you talk about the the joe montana thing
and i agree with you brady's better than
joe montana yes and obviously with the
super bowl wins too but there's another
perfect example of you know sometimes
it's just bigger than two people too you
know bill walsh retired and the 49ers
went on to have one of the greatest
seasons in the history of their
organization maybe their best team ever
you know joe montana left the 49ers and
all they did was go to nfc championship
games and then won a super bowl so you
know it's bigger than two people at
times too even though we're in this era
of putting two guys next to each other
my biggest bs meter moment mike was when
he talked about and again i i don't want
to sound insensitive but the fact that
he couldn't go to otas because he had to
be around his wife and his family more
you know that's where i went oh i don't
know if i buy that i think you might be
sticking it to the new england patriots
with that stuff first off otas are not a
long grueling day mike you're the day
starts at eight you're home by 12 45.
it's not like you can't spend time and
then there's what how many of them 12 of
them 14 of them so that to me was a bs
um
answer okay and i know he's a good
family man and a good husband and all
that i'm not denying that but i think
that was the start of him kind of
sticking it to new england for the years
of hey not patting me on the back not
paying me the money i'm not going to go
to otas and i'll use my family as kind
of an excuse that was the one that kind
of went up on my bs meter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports